[Musique]
bon bah ça devrait aller cette affaire
là qu'à repérer ce que j'ai fait oui je
crois que ça doit marcher
bonjour à tous bonjour à tout instant
d'émotion et des sciences car la sphère
est délicate vous dire bonjour oui je
vais le faire à la télévision où il dit
bonjour madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour monsieur on bat du doigt c'est
bien sûr et moniales cette affaire-là
dans le cycle mais je ingénieux de tout
cas encore voici le verre d'eau ou
renversés et enfin ça on va essayer
explique c'est très simple vous prenez
un verre
bon vous le remplissez d'eau à ras bord
met alors à ras bord parce que regarder
bien voyez faut essayer ça devrait aller
là je crois que l'eau effectivement ça
va vous prenez une feuille de papier du
morceau de papier tout simple son
problème comme celui là et vous
l'appliquez sur le verre d'eau de façon
à ce que il adhère bien adhèrent bien
alors il faut pas légèrement le maître
comme ceci tapoter sur les bords du
verre je demande tout votre
concentration là parce que c'est
extrêmement délicat voilà la cbi là tu
es très bien c'est bien là oui oui c'est
bon bon
alors maintenant qualifié d' au moins il
le démontre bien
oui alors maintenant vous prenez le vert
vous leur tournée d'un coup brusque et
puis qui va se passer oui mais moi je
suis inquiet adaptation puisque tu l'as
fait a réussi genève d'une effet c'est
sûr je vais le faire oui bah tu as un
moral attention expériences en cours
je vais renverser la faire complètement
que chacun retient son souffle
1 2 et 3 au à table alors je leur mets
une fois brillant c'est pas mal et on
peut le faire ou tourner autant de fois
qu'on veut tu avais
simple il faut un verre de l'eau une
petite feuille de papier c'est pas très
compliqué - oui un petit peu de patience
à un peu de doigté et ça doit aller tout
seul alors je suis quand même content de
l'avoir réussi puisque j'étais un petit
peu inquiète voit les centres et les
cela ne les ont pas devrait faire plus
tard bon bah d'arette toute attente bon
ben maintenant je sors play fabrique oui
je connais système
je sors nous sommes d'accord oui moi je
vais retrouver mes petits amis je viens
trouver belle belle je vais retrouver
pouces moussu je suis bien content moi
je me sens bien quand je suis avec vénus
moussu ah non vous n'êtes pas saisie moi
je suis très drôle et léger comme tous
moussu oui oui mais aussi ont la balle
est allée la paix fabrice payet oui ça y
est on est prêts à les acheter
voilà je vous l oeil c'est parce qu'ils
m'ont préparé mais je sens que je suis
dans une très bonne forme alors me
suivent c'est le point commun
donc je nous allons tous les trois sont
plutôt chacun de nous on va te raconter
une petite histoire qui nous avons un
point commun qui nous lie à la wii
d'accord oui alors vous pouvez être
n'importe quoi alors je rassure moi je
vais te dire par exemple aujourd'hui moi
je suis un morceau de gruyère il met
alors à temps je voudrais avant que tu
ne t'énerve pas ce que je te sens très
impatient d'attaquer un oui je sais bien
que tous nos amis participent également
et qu'ils doivent eux-mêmes découvrir ce
point commun sommes bien d'accord
cela va de soi oui mais vous mieux le
redire tout bon je t'écoute alors je te
disais ouais je suis à morceau de
gruyère bien appétissant enfin quand je
dis gruyère je pourrais aussi bien dire
emmental ou compter un bref tu sais je
suis anne ses fromages qu'on fabrique
sur les versants des vosges ou de ces
petites vallées de la suisse ou où les
vaches font entendre au loin les cloches
qu'on suspend alors qu'août vaduz dans
dieu que le son des cloches oui enfin
bref de poésie alors enfin voila je suis
un morceau de gruyère
alors moi je suis un petit chemin de
campagne de ces chemins dont je ne sais
pas très bien s'il mène quelque part je
ne suis pas voudront ni je suis pas très
bien entretenu je ne possède pas de
panneau indicateur du genre vitesse
limitée à 90 km heure c'est moi on ne
risque pas d'excès de vitesse
je peux même vous dire qu'après en gros
orage je suis totalement impraticable à
un conseil ne venez pas me rendre visite
à voiture vous n'en sortirez pas à
l'abri bah moi moi moi j'ai honte à le
dire mais je ne suis pas grand chose je
suis pas grand chose je suis qu'une
vieille chaussette
et oui vous avez bien entendu une
vieille chaussette je crois que je ne
servirai plus jamais à rien à quand
j'étais jeune j'étais élégante on a là
j'avais une jolie couleur bleu foncé
avec une jolie rayures rouges et
maintenant ben on me traite comme un
vieux chiffons alors j'ai demandé jeudi
matin et a pas moyen d essayer de me
raccommoder on m'a dit non non non aux
non c'est pas possible dans cet état là
c'est pas possible je suis bien triste
vous savez ça je ne vous souhaite pas
d'en arriver là
voilà c'est tout alors on résume s'est
révélé bien raison nous avons dans une
vieille chaussette quand les chemins de
campagne mal entretenus et avoir son
gruyère
oui et il pensait nous piéger avec ça
franchement est-ce qu'il est difficile
de trouver un point commun entre le
morceau de gruyère la vieille chaussette
et le chemin de campagne c'est pas si
facile que ça c'est enfantin
nous avons tous trouvé tous et nous
pouvons le dire
ah bon les trous et loudenvielle trou
dans le chemin de campagne et trous dans
la vieille chaussette voilà ce n'était
pas écrit c'était bien quand même
c'était bien enfin nous sommes devenus
très fort tous ensemble méfiez-vous
méchoui s'attaquant même fait faire des
progrès ce je crois à une certaine ça à
développer ton intelligence
oui autant qu'on va tout à l'heure tu
sais pas belle à voir belles belles
belles belles c'est le jeu de pouce
boussu je vais le dire à fabrice fabrice
oui c'est le jeu de pouce moussu avoir
reçu sept emplois oui c'est à moi c'est
à moi rêver bah c'est mon jeu comme
toutes les semaines c'est mon petit jeu
à moi alors tu es d'accord
bon alors cette semaine c'est un mot de
huit lettres
tu vas attend petits tableaux oui oui si
tu veux oui tu as ton petit crayon pour
écrire son jus tout bon car 0,3 alors
cette semaine un bond en huit lettres en
huile être une lettre bon ah oui qui
commence qui commence par un ses parents
c'est à 1 c à reims et voilà le feu
cessera
alors tu fais six petits points ou 6
petites rai 1 but 2 3 4 5 et 6 et la
dernière lettre c'est un e à 1 1 voilà
tu vas bientôt
oui là je vois je vois c'est parfait
alors je commence les questions ah oui
attention on écoute je suis certain que
c'est un animal
oh oh bah tu es formidable il est
instable a failli mère tu as trouvé tout
de suite tu choisis tout le temps des
animaux a d'abord sceptique oui alors
est ce que c'est un gros animal
oh non il n'est pas très grand non non
non est ce que c'est un tout petit
animal est pas tout non plus
les moyens ni les moyens regard est ce
que c'est un animal sauvage non aux
dépôts sauvages du tout non non non mais
chan ho non par des jours on aura plutôt
inoffensif 3906 à huy est ce que c'est
un animal domestique
non non non ont eu mal on n'a pas ça
chez soir au nom on aura moment rarement
chez soi cramant chez moi oui chez moi
sur toi tu en as oui oui moi je n'en ai
pas non est ce que c'est un animal est
ce que c'est un animal que l'on voit
souvent se promenant dans une forêt par
la wii avait oui oui oui dans les forêts
dans les bois tout compris alors on
pourrait peut-être est-ce que c'est un
animal qui court très vite et que paris
y glisser et ce qu'ils rampent wiirock
c'est ça joue là que tu te donnes une
lettre pour t'aider un peu parce que je
ne tente que si tu veux pas un voilà je
vais te donner la la quatrième lettre
oui la quatrième c1 elle alors ll alors
1 2 3 4 quatrième n'était pas là tu me
dis que ça remplace à rentrer lui arrive
à trouver que ça arrive à trouver je
suis sûr qu'il va être sa rampe avec un
c ça finit par un e
alors là je pense bien un animal
évidemment tout le monde me pende
seulement ça colle pas est ce que tu
m'as dit ça colle pas un animal qui
remplit qui commence par ac qui finit
par année 7 pourrait être une couleuvre
oui bah c'est celle avec marie
couleuvres course n'a su comment je sais
que madaba couleur3 couleuvres coup
lèvres alors à nos couleurs
1 e i au pouce moussu couleurs à guy
mais enfin mais vous savez vous êtes
tous les deux nuls en tapotant josaphat
heures et enfin qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça couleuvres chacun sait que
couleuvres s'écrit comme cela c'est au
elle y écrit pas très bien mais je fais
ce que je peux vrs que vous arrivez à
bien le lire ses couleurs c'est alors
couleur3 juillet une lettre alors oui
mais tu fais n'importe quoi qui peut
parler toi
ah bah je peux parler tu ne perds pas
dit comment ça s'écrit cher en tout cas
moi je peux vous dire que quand j'étais
petit à main je savais pas reconnaître
une couleuvre une couleur d'une vipère
vu la couleur
elle n'est pas dangereuse youtube tandis
que la vipère alors oh là là mais en
tout cas la couleur des ailes à une
queue qui qui serait tracy très
progressivement mais c'est comme ça
comme un gros ver de terre
et tandis que la vipère un l et une
queue qui brusquement devient toute
mince il paraît qu'on peut aussi les
reconnaître d'après la forme de la tête
en tout cas moi j'ai pas envie
d'attendre qu'elles soient trop près de
moi pour savoir comment elle s'appelle
alors je préfère mon système voir on va
faire sa marque tu as raison parce que
finalement il vaut mieux être prudent
dans ce genre oh i o fauqué boyet
savidan c'est important
oui tout cas encore puisque c'est toi
qui préside un petit pipi les jeux
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce que je dois
faire maintenant toi qu'il sait tous à
leur ami josh te propose un concert a
construit un très joli concert avec une
idée de nos plus jolie voix une des plus
jolies voix de la fort
oui elle est belle elle va chanter elle
va chanter ballon sociale
[Musique]
non
qui
la selle jury lui à lyon mais il ya
toutefois eu deux mois
et si nombre y voit l'un des salons les
noirs jeu
[Musique]
ah oui ah oui oui ça c'est au niveau
carrément de la crise à leur sortie
c'est exact et que c'est bruyant on
n'est pas eu du mal à la tête
l'une de ces migraines taper comme ça
qu'est ce que c'est la sas et c'est un
tambour ça autant et j'ai une tête à
jouer du tambour tu me prends pour garde
champêtre cet instrument est un tam-tam
tully rapporté d'afrique du sénégal si
tu veux tout savoir oui mon vieux salir
amusant je peux essayer d'en jouer ah
oui mais alors attention ne la bim non
non tu vas voir aller à temps bravo
avant tout cas encore bon viable oui
pensez rien ah bah ouais je joue mieux
ses vraies belles belles mais toi tu
sais tout faire
tu as toutes les qualités je peux pas
lutter avec toi les modestes en plus il
faut le remarquer est ce que ça veut
dire
lorient a pris son sens qu'est-ce que tu
es signe encore du tout moi je fais une
crise de jalousie pas vrai ils montent à
7 e rang furieux que je mène une vie
passionnante qui m'envient rassure toi
aujourd'hui je ne mettrai pas en colère
je garderai tout mon calme j'ai tout à
l'heure en rendez vous très important et
je ne veux pas y arriver sans doute sur
touques encore mais je sais déjà que je
m'adresse parce que fabrice décidément
ça n'est pas très intéressant entre nous
oui alors tu peux des coachs et de
wattignies avec le grand sorcier bobo il
est de passage à paris avant le repas je
ne montrerai la tour eiffel nous y
monteront s'ils le souhaitent
boba om latitude il m'a fait grimper
surtout les gratte-ciel de son village à
la fin j'ai trouvé ça tu peux postuler
eux mais par ailleurs il s'est montré si
aimable il m'a tout montrer de son
merveilleux pays
avec lui j'ai remonté la casamance à
bord d'une pirogue talent en tant
qu'équipe qu'est ce que c'est que ça la
casamance un fleuve
réaction du village les indigènes nous
faisait de grands signes de la matière
et des enfants qui jouaient à l'heure
des repas
c'était tout à fait pittoresque de les
apercevoir nu assis sous les cocotiers
ils mangeaient leurs spaghetti quotidien
de six bel appétit quelqu'un aux lois
jouait du tabac
[Musique]
je suis revenu avec des cotonnades
multicolores des chaussures en peau de
phoque des colliers de coquillages un
masque il est mon souvenir le plus
marquant voillot fabrice est intéressant
est prodigieusement on tirait pas tant
mais si je suis très heureux pour elle
aura peut être un succès voyons dans mes
souvenirs que cherche il ya eu dakar la
capitale
le cap vert très très vert oui très très
beau le cap vert et puis cette ville ici
c'est cette visite
fabuleusement authume agace si tu me
regardent comme ça tu ne fais pas fois
dans l'en-but j'écoute je lui ai alors
j'ai donc pris 1
alors je parle de cette visite a une
carrière de marbre
c'était passionnant d'ailleurs tout m'a
passionné je suis passionnée par tout tu
n'es jamais allé en afrique noire jamais
mis les pieds au sénégal où étais tu
dois te regarde ailleurs la prèv oui
j'ai entendu dire que si tu avais les
salles et des preuves du monde a donné
beaucoup tu m'as dit par exemple
oui les tice je suis une excellente
contesti victor ont été dressés en
conteste uran tu comptes très bien tu
racontes même des tas de choses
étonnantes louis spaghettis est fréquent
dans les villages africains espérait
lever les gratte-ciel dans les villages
africains extrêmement fréquent sa wii
également oui et puis la carrière de
marbre je te dire au sénégal
partout des cartes et mon team creux de
côté ce qu'estime est je pense
qu'effectivement tu es tu sais pas très
bien de quoi tu parles
qu'est ce que tu me dis je dis que je
suis certain que rythme
part du sénégal sont d'y être vraiment à
les femmes je t'en prie
quand on voyage autant que moi oui peut
bien s'en milieu un peu dans ses
souvenirs
oui oui alors la ccao revoir bel bel au
revoir et à bientôt au sénégal au revoir
mais légal a battu là encore fâché
bon ok c'est pas raisonnable c'est pas
bien grave de toute façon tu sais bien
qu'elle adore raconter des histoires
belle belle avec son histoire du sénégal
à très sérieux quand même vous
franchement nous parler de gratte ciel
vous parlez de peaux de phoque nous
parler de carrière de marbre et nous
parler de spaghettis non les villages
donc la salle pas sérieux non je n'ai
pas bien bougé hamel au sénégal tulsa
casamance el haddioui notamment la
casamance bon tout le monde sait que
c'est un fleuve du sénégal et puces et
oui enfin le reste non crois moi ça
n'empêchera pas de revenir la prochaine
fois nous raconter une histoire meneur
dans l'air de vous c'est à dire
elle reviendra parce que elle nous aime
bien ça c'est vrai on aime bien aussi
d'ailleurs
wayne rooney bref on aime pas qu elles
nous racontent n'importe quoi
il dort je proposerais bien quelque
chose le ver encore abouti on est encore
une petite fois levé renversé elle aime
le risque de toi oui on va essayer mais
je ne garantis rien petite expérience
que nous avons fait au début de
l'émission
je vous rappelle l'essentiel ce qu'il
faut pour réussir cette expérience un
verre plein d'eau un papier mis sur ce
ver de façon à ce qu'il soit le plus
proche possible des bords du verre ou
non avec la main on peut faire ça ça le
connaissait bien et il touche bien
entendu la surface de l'eau tout le
problème consiste à renverser ce ver
assez rapidement alors nous allons le
faire si ça marche
attention 1 2 3 up très bien je
recommence sa attention je marche un set
a réussi un joli coup là attention 1 2
et 3
et voilà bon je vous souhaite de réussir
cette expérience si vous aviez un petit
problème demander de l'aide à votre papa
votre moment où à votre
en frérot avait trop grande soeur et ne
mettez pas de l'eau dans tout
l'appartement la maison car alors là
j'aurais des problèmes ce sont aux
parents qui seraient pas contents j'ai
compris au revoir à tous à très bientôt
je continue
[Musique]